Megan and I met over Instagram and I was
like who is that Megan Markle and Prince
Harry just revealed they met on Insta
Instagram talk about a plot twist and
the whole thing is giving major modern
day fairy tale Vibes yes I guess she is
a bit of a modern day Cinderella on
Thursday Netflix dropped the first three
episodes of the six-part docu-series
Harry and Megan and the Duke and Duchess
of Sussex are getting candid about those
early days of their relationship I was
scrolling through my feed and uh someone
who was a friend had this video of the
two of them was like a Snapchat oh gosh
this isn't that whole thing it says like
dog ears that's what he saw of me
there's no doubt he's into her and she's
most certainly into him it's a bit of a
whirlwind romance well that Whirlwind
romance kicked off when Harry and
Megan's mutual friend sent Megan email
saying she had a pal who wanted to meet
her who is it and she said it's Prince
has and I said who's that
I asked if I could see his feed
that's the thing when people say did you
Google them no but I that's your
homework you're like
they're about in their feet celebs
they're just like us
he went digging through his feet people
so I went through and it was just like
beautiful
photography and all these environmental
shots and this time he was spinning in
Africa
of course we all know what happened next
the two fell in love and tied the knot
in 2018 with the whole world watching
there is no question of a doubt that
Meghan markle's life has changed
suddenly she is the most talked about
woman in the world and Harry talks
openly about the personal sacrifices
they've both made to stay together you
know she sacrificed everything that she
ever knew the freedom that she had to
join me in my world
and then pretty soon after that I ended
up sacrificing everything that I know
to join her in her world of course Harry
is referring to their January 2020
decision to step back from their Royal
duties and begin a new life in Montecito
California where they are now raising
their two children Archie and lilibet it
is of course a beautiful home it's a
forever home and somewhere where they'll
lay their Roots they're really able to
now create a safe space away from prying
eyes the docu-series is part of a
multi-year deal Megan and Harry signed
with Netflix back in September 2020. the
next three episodes drop December 15th
it's really hard to look back on it now
and go what on Earth happened and next
up were the couple Harry's upcoming
Memoir titled spare which is slated to
release on January 10th Harry has taken
a 35 million dollar advance that's not
going to be for Harry talking about his
philanthropic work that's going to be
the inside story of being born the spare
and we are told the royal family is
worried about it and I think the
greatest threat and the greatest concern
certainly for the Royals is the force
coming autobiography which is of course
caused a lot of consternation in Royal
circles a lot of concern among senior
Royal sources and and Palisades because
quite simply they don't know what to
expect
[Music]
thank you